When we originally funded the Gates Scholarship in 2000,...
...we wanted it to help exceptional students from all over the world...
...experience Cambridge's 800-year legacy of higher education.
Twenty years later, this scholarship has reached...
...more than 2,000 students from 111 different countries.
Gates Cambridge Scholars are now fighting for human rights,...
...working to defeat COVID, and creating solutions...
...to avoid climate change.
My dad's parents never finished high school,...
...and so, he always saw education...
...as the thing that gave him opportunity.
You and I want the world to be a better place,...
...we're very anxious that it be better for as near to everybody...
...as we can possibly make it.
He dearly loved this University and this program,...
...and once said, that, of all the grants we ever made,...
...this was his favorite.
What you're doing is producing effective, thoughtful leadership.
It may seem small but, you know, over 20 years,...
...we're talking about quite a few thoughtful,...
...sophisticated, well-motivated leaders.
And it's as simple as that.
Even though my dad is no longer with us,...
...the Gates Cambridge Scholarship program...
...is an embodiment of his most cherished beliefs.
That given the opportunity, human beings will come together...
...and make the world a better place for everyone.